[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen auf die Frage was sein
Land jetzt besonders dringend brauche
zur Verteidigung gegen die russischen
Angriffe hat der zuständige Minister der
Ukraine heute drei Antworten Munition
Munition Munition die
verteidigungsministerkollegen aus der EU
haben ihm dabei aufmerksam zugehört nur
wirklich helfen konnten sie nicht denn
Europa hat drei Probleme erstens die
EU-Staaten haben selbst enorme Engpässe
zweitens es wird nur ein Bruchteil der
Munition aktuell produziert die die
Ukraine bräuchte und drittens das ganze
ist sehr sehr teuer aus Stockholm wo
Europa zusammen sitzt und angesichts der
Situation so etwas wie die Quadratur des
Kreises versucht berichtet Florian neu
an als erstes kommt an diesem Morgen in
Stockholm einen Mitarbeiter bevor die
Kameras die Minister verspäten sich sagt
er nur ein paar Minuten Mann bitte um
Verständnis
es werden dann ein paar Minuten mehr es
hat nichts mit Inhalten zu tun bloß mit
dem Schnee in Schweden und doch passt es
zu gut zu dieser Sitzung der
eu-verteidigungsminister in Stockholm
seit Monaten schließlich waren ein
Ukrainer wie westliche Generäle dem Land
geht langsam die Munition aus während
Russland pro Tag so viel Munition
verschieße wie die gesamte EU in einem
einzigen Monat produzieren können doch
erst nach Monaten der Warnungen im
zweiten Jahr des Kriegs ziemlich spät
also beschließt Europa jetzt zu
reagieren
es gab eine grundsätzliche Einigung alle
waren sich einig dass wir uns jetzt
schnell bewegen müssen
es soll so laufen wie in der letzten
großen Krise als die eu-zentral für alle
corona-impfstoffe einkaufte die Idee
große Mengen zu kleinen Preisen besorgen
jetzt auch bei der Munition der Plan hat
nur einen Haken bis die
Rüstungsindustrie ihre Produktion von
Geschossen wie diesen hochgefahren hat
dürfte es dauern zu lang findet der
EU-Kommissar für den Binnenmarkt Thierry
Breton bringt einen umstrittenen Begriff
ins Spiel
es ist unbedingt erforderlich dass wir
jetzt auf eine Art Kriegswirtschaft
umstellen was Nachschub und
Rüstungsindustrie betrifft
angefangen ich mache mir den Begriff
Kriegswirtschaft definitiv nicht zu
eigen die Europäische Union Deutschland
wir sind nicht im Krieg Kriegswirtschaft
heißt dass wir alles der Produktion von
Waffen und Munition unterordnen das wäre
nun wirklich ein völlig fatales Signal
auf kurze Sicht also bleibt nichts
anderes als den Mangel zu verwalten um
der Ukraine in den nächsten wieder
entscheidenden Wochen helfen zu können
müssen Europas starten ihre eigenen
Reserven öffnen und versprechen daraus
heute Munition im Wert von einer
Milliarde Euro
das ist nicht genug wir brauchen eine
Million Artillerie Geschosse das wird 4
Milliarden Euro kosten
Kiew setzt Europa unter Druck es ist ein
gewohntes Bild in diesem Krieg auch
heute in Stockholm und Europa reagiert
genauso wie gewohnt mit Verspätung
ja während die EU debattiert und den
Mangel verwaltet ist der Ernstfall
weiter östlich Teil des Alltags geworden
mein Kollege Henna Hebestreit hat in der
Ukraine einen beeindruckenden Künstler
getroffen der leise Klänge klassischer
Musik eintauschen musste gegen den
Donner der Schlachtfelder aber die
Hoffnung nicht aufgeben will dass er
auch wieder zurück kann
die großen Konzertsäle der Ukraine hat
er schon gespielt sehr geileco gehört zu
den berühmtesten Dirigenten seines
Landes
der letzte Applaus ist schon lange
verklungen denn kurz nach Kriegsbeginn
hat er den Frack gegen fleckan getauscht
die regiert jetzt den Nachschub für die
Armee
Chirurgen die jetzt im Lazarett
operieren um leben unsere Soldaten zu
retten aber auch der Zivilbevölkerung
helfen jetzt müssen wir zum nächsten
Postamt fahren um neues Darlings
abzuholen
Holz und quer geht es durch grammatos
der Hauptstadt der Oblast Donezk die
Front ist nicht weit immer wieder
erreichte Krieg die Stadt
Nummer eins wurde von einer Rakete
getroffen das nimmt jetzt keine Pakete
mehr an alles wird jetzt hier hin zur
Postnummer 5 geliefert
Dirigent serchi hat sich längst ans
Schleppen schwerer Kartons gewöhnt aber
nicht an die Trennung von seinem
Orchester
sie sind alle nach Polen gefahren um auf
dem musikalischen Schlachtfeld zu
arbeiten das ist ja auch Kommunikation
sie sind fast Verwandte für mich jeder
hat seine Besonderheiten es ist aber wie
eine musikalische Familie das fehlt mir
und deshalb freut er sich sehr über den
Auftrag eine Hymne für das fünfte
Regiment zu schreiben das ist ganz neu
und hat noch keine eigene
Erkennungsmelodie mit seinem Produzenten
André arbeitet er in einer kleinen
Kirche an der Komposition
[Musik]
ist ein großer Organismus es arbeitet
genauso koordiniert wie eine
militärische Einheit es gibt es
Schlagzeug das ist die Artillerie
schützen sind Geiger von denen braucht
es viele die Aufgabe jedes einzelnen ist
genau bestimmt wenn das alles passt dann
entsteht ein Meisterwerk
[Musik]
und genau so eines wollen Serie und
andere jetzt für Regiment komponieren
der Krieg verändert die Musik aber auch
die die sie machen
seine Bewegungen waren früher sanft und
abgerundet jetzt sind sie viel heftiger
die tägliche Erfahrung von Leid und Tod
hinterlässt ihre Spuren im Spiel ist
Dirigenten der jetzt ein Krieger ist
[Musik]
unser nächstes Thema klar ist die
Pipelines für russisches Gas Richtung
Deutschland auf dem Grund der Ostsee
sind Geschichte klar ist auch der
Sprengstoffanschlag war ein Sabotageakt
der ganz Europa nervös macht die große
Frage allerdings wer wahr ist die ist
noch unklar aber es tut sich was die
Bundesanwaltschaft bestätigt heute Teile
der Recherchen der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bei ARD und der Zeit die hatten
über eine heiße Fährte berichtet die in
Deutschland beginnt und Richtung Ukraine
weist die offizielle Sprachregelung der
Bundesregierung heute wir sehen das mit
großem Interesse aber wir sollten
abwarten was sich tatsächlich bestätigt
Diana zimmermann
die Webcam des Hafens Rostock auch die
Bewegungen vom 6 September kann man hier
nachvollziehen Spoilerwarnung das Schiff
das von hier aus aufgebrochen sein soll
die Pipelines zu zerstören konnten wir
nicht entdecken der ganze Fall aber
erregt nicht nur die Gemüter von
hobby-ermittlern seit am 26 September
das Wasser bei Bornholm in Wallung
geriet weil tief im Meer die Rohre der
Nord Stream explodierten wird gerätselt
wer die Täter waren mit bislang magerem
Erfolg die einzige wirkliche News kam
heute von der Bundesanwaltschaft ja der
Generalbundesanwalt habe im Januar ein
Schiff auf Sprengstoff untersuchen
lassen Identität der Täter und Tat
Motive sei noch nicht geklärt belastbare
Aussagen hierzu insbesondere zur Frage
einer staatlichen Steuerung können
derzeit nicht getroffen werden
dennoch haben die gestern erschienenen
Medienberichte die Tätergruppe sei pro
Ukrainisch für Aufruhr gesorgt fünf
Männer und eine Frau mit gefälschten
Pässen sollen von Rostock aus
aufgebrochen sein über den dars Richtung
Bornholm und Tatort kein Hobby
Unterfangen so CDU-Außenpolitiker
Kiesewetter hier ist hochprofessionell
agiert worden mit Sprengstoffen die es
nicht ohne weiteres auf dem Markt
verfügbar gibt hier ist agiert worden in
70 Meter Tiefe da reicht auch nicht eine
Yacht sondern das müssen mehrere Schiffe
gewesen sein und da waren Profis am Werk
die eine nachrichtendienstliche
beziehungsweise auch eine intensive
Spezialausbildung haben viel zu
kompliziert für die Geheimdienste der
Ukraine versucht deren
Verteidigungsminister zu Witzen
für mich ist das eine ziemlich seltsame
Geschichte sie hat nichts mit uns zu tun
ich denke dass eine offizielle
Untersuchung durch die zuständigen
Behörden alle Details klären wird es
wäre ein gewisses Kompliment an unsere
Spezialeinheiten aber es waren nicht
unsere Aktivität
und doch ist es für Kiew sehr unangenehm
dass die Täter nun als pro-ukraine
bezeichnet werden Moskau dagegen
frohlockt behauptet aber weiterhin
eigentlich stecke Washington hinter der
Aktion auch der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister rätselt noch sehr
differenziert wir müssen ja deutlich
unterscheiden ob es eine ukrainische
Gruppe war also im ukrainischen Auftrag
gewesen sein könnte oder eine
pro-okrainische ohne Wissen der
Regierung aber ich warne davor voreilige
Schlüssel zu ziehen Boris Pistorius sagt
auch dass das ganze eine fondsflag
Operation gewesen sein könnte also der
versucht die Tat der Ukraine anzuhängen
mit Hochdruck wird bei diesem Krimi auf
hoher See weiter nach Tätern und
Auftraggebern gesucht wenigstens aber
nach belastbaren Ermittlungsergebnisse
das war nicht das letzte Mal dass wir
darüber berichtet haben eine Millionen
Betriebe zählen zum deutschen Handwerk
mit fast 6 Millionen Menschen die dort
arbeiten und dennoch muss wer gerade zum
Beispiel sein Bad renovieren will fasst
ein halbes Jahr auf Handwerker warten
und wenn die dann tatsächlich da waren
folgt häufig eine saftige Rechnung das
Handwerk stöhnt und zwar gleich doppelt
die einen kommen bei den Aufträgen nicht
mehr hinterher andere haben Angst vor
bauflaute und Konjunktur Dellen ab heute
haben sie alle fünf Tage lang in München
Gelegenheit um Lösungen zu suchen für
die Zukunft es ist handwerksmesse und
zwar die größte ihrer Art in Deutschland
Patricia Schäfer
später Vormittag in einer Münchner
Backstube Junior Chef Sebastian
brücklmeier und seine Mitarbeiter
bereiten Körner Semmeln vor die müssen
am nächsten Morgen nur noch in den Ofen
geschoben werden die Dinge die wir nicht
unbedingt in der Nacht machen müssen da
schauen wir schon dass wir die am Tag
erledigen können sehr viel angenehmer am
Tag zu arbeiten und deswegen haben wir
auch eine sozusagen Spätschicht für
bäckerzeichen eingeführt die beginnen
erst um 5 Uhr und die endet um 13:30 Uhr
zwei Stunden später anfangen für Bäcker
ist das wie ausschlafen durch diese
Spätschicht hat der Bäckereibetrieb es
geschafft mehr junge Leute für den Beruf
zu begeistern dabei helfen kann auch
mehr gesellschaftliche Anerkennung aber
da tut sich was
früher wurde ich belächelt als ich
während des Abiturs gesagt habe ja ich
studiere nicht ich mache eine Bäcker
Ausbildung aber mittlerweile glaube ich
spätestens wären Corona hat sich das
Platten bisschen gewendet nicht zuletzt
weil es ein systemrelevanter Beruf ist
und ja jetzt ist irgendwie die die
Wahrnehmung war cool der ist Becker die
Anerkennung wächst ist aber bei weitem
noch nicht groß genug sagt Jörg Dittrich
oberster Vertreter des deutschen
Handwerks
die Zeit drängt wenn sich nicht bald
mehr Jugendliche für eine berufliche
Ausbildung entscheiden gehen tausende
Handwerksbetriebe unter schon heute
fehlen 250.000 Handwerker sagte deren
Zentralverband 19.000 Lehrstellen
blieben unbesetzt deshalb fordert
Dietrich auf der Münchner handwerksmesse
mehr Gleichstellung von Azubis mit
Studenten es ist für Studenten normal
Semesterticket Wohnheime zur
Studentenwohnheime diese identische
Ausfinanzierung der beruflichen Bildung
muss kommen und wenn wir den Deutschen
Akademischen Austauschdienst sehen dann
ist ein Vorschlag auch der deutsche
berufliche Austauschdienst es muss zur
Normalität werden dass ein
Auszubildender genauso eine
Auslandsaufenthalt machen kann wie das
heutzutage ein Student wird dabei will
auch eher mit Hand anlegen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister nahm sich
heute viel Zeit für einen Besuch der
handwerksmesse und kündigt politische
Entscheidungen an
das ist genug Menschen gibt die Arbeiten
können wir haben gigantische Fachkräfte
Lücken auch beim Handwerk
und die Attraktivität des Berufes durch
Respekt aber tatsächlich auch gleich bzw
durch politische Gleichstellungen
Aufwertung mit anderen Berufen finde ich
eine völlig berechtigte Forderung
Rückenwind für das Handwerk Klimawende
und Digitalisierung sei nur möglich wenn
das Handwerk funktioniert zu der
Wirtschaftsminister es werde zum
Konjunkturmotor verspricht er sogar
große Worte denen nun auch Taten folgen
müssen
ja schauen wir mal wir haben ihn gerade
schon kurz gesehen Jörg Dietrich ist der
handwerks-präsident er ist relativ neu
im Amt aber hat viel Erfahrung in seinem
Familienbetrieb als Dachdecker Herr
Dietrich schönen guten Abend
guten Abend Handwerk hat goldenen Boden
heißt es ja sprichwörtlich was ist da
dran
dieser Spruch gilt eindeutig von der
Sinnhaftigkeit und natürlich auch von
dem was Menschen die dort arbeiten
verdienen können die Löhne steigen jetzt
ist es ja aktuell so aus Kundensicht
gesprochen egal wohin man guckt wer
einen Handwerker braucht muss im Moment
ewig warten so scheint es zumindest für
die Kunden sieht es aus als ob es sich
gerade wunderbar Geld verdienen lässt
weil sie ja offenbar vor Aufträgen nur
so strotz
ewig warten würde ich so nicht
unterschreiben es gibt Wartezeiten aber
auf ein Auto müssen sie auch viele
Monate warten es ist nicht so schlimm
wenn man mal sechs oder zwölf Wochen auf
ein neues Bad oder ein neues Dach warten
muss problematisch wird das Ganze wenn
es viel mehr wird weil es viel zu wenig
fachkräftig gibt darauf müssen wir
achten ja wenn ihr euch also ein halbes
Jahr für einen Klempner bis der Klempner
kommt das kann ja nicht die Zukunft sein
können Sie denn den Menschen verdenken
wenn sie dann zunehmend auch auf
Schwarzarbeit möglicherweise ausweichen
für Havarie Fälle muss das Handwerk
natürlich eher kommen das tut es in den
meisten Fällen auch aber sie sprechen
mit der Schwarzarbeit natürlich genau
das an was passiert wenn wir die
falschen Weichen stellen wenn
Handwerksleistung unbezahlbar wird weil
wir weil wir Abgaben und Steuerlasten
haben die das Produkt dann unbezahlbar
machen deswegen muss es ein Umsteuern
geben genau in der beruflichen Bildung
wir wollen unsere Kolleginnen und
Kollegen besser entlohnen sie wollen sie
besser entlohnen sagen sie aber
gleichzeitig es muss ja irgendwie auch
bezahlbar bleiben jetzt für die Menschen
die Handwerksleistungen in Anspruch
nehmen wie wollen Sie denn diesen Spagat
lösen am Ende
wir brauchen einen Umsteuern das beginnt
bei bürokratischen Lasten die Kosten
erzeugen wir wirken uns quasi in der
Transformation mit der Bürokratie selbst
ab und dazu kommt dass die
Sozialversicherungssysteme traditionell
seit über 100 Jahren sehr stark am Lohn
hängen dieses wird sich ändern müssen
ein Stück weit weil wir auch viele
andere Geschäftsmodelle haben und die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit von lohnintensiven
Berufen dann nicht mehr gegeben ist sie
haben nicht nur den Lohn für den
Kollegen die Kollegen sie haben
Sozialkosten sie haben Geschäftskosten
und das treibt den Preis und dort müssen
wir eingreifen damit die Leistungen die
die Menschen brauchen auch für die
bezahlbar bleiben jetzt haben sie
natürlich auch ein riesen Problem was
viele Branchen haben das Stichwort
Fachkräfte Mangel das hört man
allerdings ich habe gerade gesagt sie
sind relativ neu im Amt als
handwerkspräsident das haben
wahrscheinlich ganze Generationen von
handwerkspräsidenten vor ihnen schon an
gemahnt passiert ist nicht viel was kann
man denn jetzt ganz konkret gegen diesen
Fachkräftemangel tun im Handwerk
wir selbst sind mit einer Imagekampagne
unterwegs seit 2010 die auch Wirkung
zeigt weil sie die Wertschätzung der
Menschen gegenüber dem Handwerk
gesteigert hat wir sind bei Social Media
unterwegs um junge Menschen anzuwerben
aber es braucht auch den politischen
Rahmen und die Mitarbeit der gesamten
Gesellschaft die Wertschätzung gegenüber
der beruflichen Bildung und das ist eine
bildungswende die wir dort vor uns haben
wir brauchen auch an den Gymnasien in
der Berufsorientierung die berufliche
Bildung die dort beraten wird es ist gut
wenn viele Menschen Abitur machen aber
sie müssen dann entsprechend ihren
Neigung trotzdem auch zum Teil in die
berufliche Bildung gehen und nicht
glauben dass nur der akademische Weg der
richtige ist Wartezeiten auf Handwerker
habe ich gerade schon genannt jetzt
besteht ja die Gefahr dass das Ganze
möglicherweise noch eine viel größere
Komponente haben könnte die ganze
Energiewende am Ende
scheitern könnte wir haben gerade den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister im Beitrag
gesehen dieses Ziel klimaneutral zu
werden in Deutschland kann es am Ende
dadurch scheitern dass zu wenig Menschen
da sind die Solaranlagen Windräder
Stromtankstellen montieren können
wer etwas für Nachhaltigkeit tun möchte
ein junger Mensch der aus dem Handwerk
natürlich genau aufgehoben
Photovoltaik-Anlagen müssen installiert
werden und es ist richtig dass wir an
dieser Stelle ansetzen müssen die junge
Menschen in das Handwerk zu bekommen
sonst haben wir keine Chance diese
Transformation hinzubekommen dort ist
das Handwerk gefragt wir kommen auch mit
Vorschlägen auf die Politik zu es ist
nicht so dass wir sagen das Ziel gefällt
uns nicht aber monothematisch nur die
Anzahl der Wärmepumpen zu zählen wird
nicht reichen wir müssen auch Fragen
gibt es die Leute gibt es das Material
ist die Finanzierung gesichert gibt es
die Stromkabel an die wir die Pumpen
anschließen wollen also wir müssen das
gesamte Spektrum betrachten und das
beginnt nun einmal damit dass wir junge
Menschen auch ins Handwerk werden ein
Appell des neuen Handwerks Präsidenten
live im heute journal Jörg Dietrich aus
München herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf das was
heute auch noch wichtig ist Hanna mit
dir ja UNO Generalsekretär gut ist Kiew
gereist um sich für eine Verlängerung
des getreideabkommens zwischen der
Ukraine und Russland einzusetzen denn
bereits in wenigen Tagen läuft das
Abkommen aus nach Gesprächen mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
betonte gotherisch die große Bedeutung
der Initiative für die
Ernährungssicherheit von Millionen von
Menschen selensky erklärte man sei einig
darüber dass die Initiative
weitergeführt werden müssen
viele Kitas und soziale Einrichtungen in
Deutschland blieben heute geschlossen
grund war ein bundesweiter Warnstreik an
dem sich laut der Gewerkschaft wer die
rund 70.000 Beschäftigte beteiligt haben
hier in Berlin mit den
Arbeitsniederlegungen will Verdi in den
festgefahrenen Tarifverhandlungen mit
Bund und Kommunen den Druck erhöhen für
den Streik wurde bewusst der
Internationale Frauentag ausgewählt da
in sozialen Berufen vor allem Frauen
arbeiten
mit einer groß angelegten Razzia ist die
Polizei Nordrhein-Westfalen gegen den
Besitz von Darstellungen von
Kindesmissbrauch vorgegangen die
Behörden durchsuchten die Wohnungen von
35 Beschuldigten in 27 Städten die
Ständen im Verdacht über einen
messenger-dienst Fotos und Videos von
sexualisierter Gewalt gegen Kinder
ausgetauscht zu haben erklärte der
Leiter der Cybercrime Einheit der
Staatsanwaltschaft Köln
das Bistum Mainz hat sich fünf Tage nach
Vorlage einer neuen missbrauchs-studie
entsetzt über die darin aufgeführten
Fälle gezeigt Bischof kohlgraf sprach
von einem Systemversagen der
katholischen Kirche zudem distanzierte
er sich von seinem Amtsvorgänger Lehmann
dieser verkörpere eine Kirche die sich
ihrer Verantwortung nicht Stelle die
unabhängige Studie hatte im katholischen
Bistum Mainz seit 1945 mindestens 401
Betroffene sexueller Übergriffe und 181
Beschuldigte ermittelt
nach den gewaltsamen Protesten gestern
sind in der georgischen Hauptstadt
Tiflis auch heute wieder tausende
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen und
gegen den Entwurf eines sogenannten
agentengesetzes zu demonstrieren einige
protestierende warfen Pyrotechnik und
rissenbarrikaden nieder die Polizei
setzte erneut Wasserwerfer ein der
umstrittene Gesetzentwurf sieht vor dass
sich Medien als ausländische Agenten
registrieren müssen wenn sie zu mehr als
20% aus dem Ausland finanziert werden
ein ähnliches Gesetz gibt es auch in
Russland
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung in ihren
Häusern einzusperren ist ein kolossaler
Akt der nationalen selbst Beschädigung
das ist ein Satz heute von der UNO aus
dem viel Verbitterung spricht und
Verzweiflung die Weltgemeinschaft muss
feststellen heute am Weltfrauentag und
ich zitiere den UNO Generalsekretär dass
der über Jahrzehnte gemachte Fortschritt
zur Gleichstellung der Frau vor unseren
Augen verschwindet
nirgendwo auf der Welt wird das so
dramatisch deutlich wie in Afghanistan
mit der Machtübernahme der Taliban ist
nicht nur die Arbeit von Soldaten und
Entwicklungshelfern zu Nichte gemacht
worden
Afghanistan wurde für Frauen und Mädchen
zum weltweit repressivsten Land und so
sagt die UNO auch alle Afghanen sind
dadurch für Generationen verurteilt zur
Armut abhängig von Hilfsgeldern Kameras
so sieht der aus der Internationale
Frauentag in Afghanistan im Zentrum von
Kabul nur wenige Frauen und wenn dann
mit verhüllten Gesicht
auch in Kabul an einem geheimen Ort
afghanische Frauen schreiben ihren
Protest nieder es lebe die Freiheit und
Nein zu Geschlechter Apartheit sie
wollen den Internationalen Frauentag
nutzen um sich und ihre Botschaften der
Welt zu zeigen
haben die Frauen ihr Recht auf Bildung
und politische gesellschaftliche und
kulturelle Teilhabe verloren sie werden
systematisch ausgegrenzt das ist ein
Verbrechen
Protest kann im heutigen Afghanistan nur
im Untergrund stattfinden das weiß auch
Schacher die 45-Jährige arbeitete früher
im Frauenministerium dann wurde es von
den Taliban geschlossen sie hat das
Treffen mit organisiert
meine letzten Rechte nehmen wenn ich
protestiere ich habe auch Angst dass
dann meine Stimme die Frauen und die
Weltöffentlichkeit nicht erreicht ich
werde aber nicht aufgeben ich kämpfe
weiter ähm
seit der Machtübernahme der Taliban ist
Frauen der Besuch von Parks und
Sporthallen verboten Schule ab der
sechsten Klasse und Universitäten
Männern vorbehalten
im Dezember haben die Taliban
afghanischen Frauen auch verboten für
nicht Regierungsorganisationen zu
arbeiten mit Ausnahmen weniger Bereiche
das hat massive Konsequenzen denn über
die Hälfte der Einwohner braucht
dringend humanitäre Hilfe
wir haben all unsere Aktivitäten hier
gestoppt weil unsere MitarbeiterInnen
nicht arbeiten dürfen aber ohne sie
können wir Frauen in den Dörfern und
Gemeinden in den Bergregionen die
dringend Winter und andere Hilfen
brauchen nicht mehr erreichen
des tugendministeriums der Taliban kennt
keinen Frauentag in seinem Weltbild sind
Frauenrechte westliche Propaganda
im Islam in der islamischen Gesellschaft
gibt es keine Unterdrückung der Frauen
daher gibt es auch keine Frauen die
gegen Unterdrückung protestieren
[Musik]
anders sie wünschen sich mehr
Solidarität der internationalen
Gemeinschaft
wir sind müde von Verurteilungen oder
Entschuldigungen die Welt muss endlich
etwas gegen die Taliban Unternehmen der
Wunsch nach einem gleichberechtigten
Afghanistan für die mutigen Frauen
bleibt der vorerst ein Wunschtraum
Bildung und Geschlechtergerechtigkeit am
Weltfrauentag mehr dazu gleich nachher
im heute-journal Update in einem
Gespräch mit der
bundesfrauenministerin jetzt aber hier
bei uns erst noch mal du Hanna ja mit
einer erstaunlich positiven Meldung aus
der Wirtschaft denn trotz aller
rezessionserwartungen für diesen Winter
sind Industriebau und Energieversorger
überraschend gut ins neue Jahr gestartet
und verzeichneten im Januar ein
Produktionsplus von 3,5% im Vergleich
zum Dezember Sina meines in Frankfurt
was sind die Gründe für diese
Entwicklung da gibt es gleich einige
unter anderem konnten energieintensive
Betriebe ihre Produktion wieder
hochfahren und die Auftragsbücher
abarbeiten die deutsche Unternehmen
haben ihre Produktion im Januar der mich
so deutlich steigern können wie seit
zweieinhalb Jahren nicht mehr und
begünstigt wurde das Ganze durch
sinkende Energiepreise nachlassende
Materialengpässe und den milden Winter
der Anstieg der Industrieproduktion fiel
damit mehr als doppelt so stark aus wie
zunächst erwartet und diese befürchtete
wirtschaftliche Abschwächung zu
Jahresbeginn könnte nun deutlich milder
ausfallen als gedacht eine
winterrezession wird nun weniger
wahrscheinlich es ist ein Aufatmen aber
noch keine Trendwende ja denn nicht
überall läuft es und lief es so rund aus
dem Einzelhandel kam heute ganz andere
Zahlen ja so ist es die Zahlen vom
Einzelhandel zeigen das wirtschaftlich
noch keine Entwarnung gegeben werden
kann diese Sparte bleibt das Sorgenkind
im Einzelhandel ist der Umsatz im Januar
überraschend gesunken besonders der in
der corona-pandemie boomende Internet
und Versandhandel verzeichnet nun ein
Minus viele Verbraucher müssen den
Gürtel enger schnallen die Preise für
Energie und Lebensmittel sind nach wie
vor hoch und die Löhne können mit diesen
Preissteigerungen nicht Schritt halten
bei einer Inflationsrate von aktuell
8,7% in Deutschland wird beim Einkauf
jeder Euro tatsächlich zweimal umgedreht
vielen Dank Sina nach Frankfurt
im langjährigen Streit zwischen dem Haus
Hohenzollern und der öffentlichen Hand
umgekehrte Eigentumsansprüche deutet
sich eine Einigung ab entsprechend
äußerte sich Georg Friedrich Prinz von
Preußen in einem Interview mit der Welt
demnach Verzicht der er als Chef des
Hauses Hohenzollern auf etwas 4000
Kunstwerke und Ausgleichszahlungen im
Mittelpunkt des Rechtsstreits stand die
Frage ob Vertreter des Hauses
Hohenzollern dem Nationalsozialismus
erheblich Vorschub geleistet haben
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
wie lauten 5 23 25 26 32 43
Superzahl 2 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
ja und mit diesen hoffentlich
Glückszahlen sagen wir danke für Ihr
Interesse heute ja und gegen 0 Uhr gibt
es dann unser heute journal Update von
uns allen einen angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Artenvielfalt
befindet sich in einer dramatischen
Krise wir sind im sechsten
Massenaussterben so die Wissenschaftler
das ist kein natürliches Ereignis
sondern wird von uns Menschen verursacht
durch die Art wie wir auf dem Planeten
leben wirtschaften und ihn verändern
gefährlich für die Artenvielfalt ist
auch die Erhitzung die global betrachtet
bereits ein Wert von etwa 1,2 Grad
erreicht hat das schränkt die
Lebensräume von Tieren und Pflanzen
zusätzlich ein denn Sie können sich an
die rasant verändernden Bedingungen
nicht anpassen bei 1,5 Grad sind vier
Prozent der Wirbeltierarten gefährdet
wie zum Beispiel der Afrikanische
Elefant der immer weniger Wasser findet
bei zwei Grad droht fast einem Fünftel
aller Insekten der Verlust ihres
Lebensraumes
wir sind derzeit leider auf dem Weg zu
drei Grad
mehr zum Atemschutz erfahren Sie heute
im ZDF in der Langen Nacht ab 1 Uhr und
jetzt schauen wir aufs Wetter da wird es
nach Norden in der Nacht schneien und es
bildet sich eine Schneedecke aus von
Schnee im Süden keine Spur hier regnet
es teils gibt es auch Gewitter bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von -3 im Norden
bis 9 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands und
morgen weiter Regen in der Mitte Schnee
der allmählich abzieht bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 15 Grad im Südwesten
und teilweise nur zwei Grad im Norden am
Freitag erreicht uns ein Sturmtief dann
wird es ungemütlich bei 2 bis 14 Grad
ein schöner Abend